this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace stick around until the end
of the video to learn more about a deal
they're making available through my
channel in a recent video I discussed
the importance of being able to train in
a way that was highly adaptable being
able to train when you have access to
less equipment being able to train if
you're injured or if you're tired or
just don't have the motivation so that
you're doing something rather than
nothing but the biggest challenge with
something like this is training max
strength if you're a power lifter and
you're really interested in max strength
then you're going to struggle to get
that in the living room because most
people can't afford or don't have space
for hundreds of kilograms worth of
weight and a power rack and if they did
have space they might have to have a
debate with their partner as to whether
that should take priority in their
living quarters and the same might be
true for bodybuilders who might also
tell me they need an awful lot of weight
in order to create muscle damage and
mechanical tension to a sufficient
degree to trigger hypertrophy I would
certainly disagree with this for
bodybuilding I think for bodybuilding
things like pre- exhausts and drop sets
and mechanical drop sets and cheats and
various ways of going past failure can
help help you to build mass for me
personally I think that going past
failure is really the secret Source when
it comes to building muscle so let's say
you want to grow your biceps but all you
have access to are some 10 kg dumbbells
and a pull-up bar what I'd recommend
doing is doing some chinups so you're
targeting the biceps slightly more and
then when you reach failure you're going
to start doing curls you've already
somewhat fatigued the biceps you're
going to fail on those curls a lot
sooner after that you're then going to
switch into hammer curls that's slightly
different technique is going to alter
the focus but it's going to allow you to
go past failure and then when you reach
failure on that start doing cheek curls
so you're going to create a little bit
of a swing and then just use your biceps
as much as you can to bring the weights
up and then lower them back down slowly
you'll feel an immense pump doing this
and I've not seen anyone not grow from
this and build up to this because of
course there is such thing as too much
muscle damage and this can be a recipe
for that if you're inexperienced
building max strength I admit is much
harder but you do have some options in
most cases you can adapt workouts and
exercises to to make them significantly
more difficult so for example maybe
you've got a big squat but how is your
pistol squat that's squatting down on
one leg if you can take a dumbbell or a
kettle bell that you have access to
maybe it's 20 30 kg put that on one side
put yourself on a slant board so that
Mobility isn't an issue use your free
hand and place it on a wall or something
so that balance isn't a limiting factor
and then squat down on one foot using
that hand for support this should be a
sufficient challenge for most people
once you start reaching the 10 or 12 rep
range likewise arm push-ups are a great
pushing exercise and the stronger you
are the heavy you're going to be so this
is going to immediately make that a bit
more difficult and if that is still too
easy then you can raise your legs up
onto something or maybe even wear a
backpack full of weight or both so I
think there are ways to get a sufficient
challenge like this and whil it's not
the exact same movement as the bench
press it's still going to translate to
more
strength so if your goal is max strength
then there's a few factors to consider
here for for example whilst you want to
be at mechanical disadvantage you want
to have a longer lever arm or you want
to be going on just one side you don't
want to fail due to balance issues so
you want to make sure you're in a nice
stable position so that you can go to
failure and so you can exert maximum
strength this is why a pistol squat on
its own might not be a great substitute
for squats at the same time you want it
to be a compound movement so you're
training lots of muscles just like the
squat just like the bench press but not
so compound that you're going to fail
because of a lack of coordination you
might have the best bench press in the
world but I'm betting that most people
who have a big bench press still can't
do a plch push-up but a plch push-up is
such a skill-based movement they're
failing because maybe their core is
giving out or maybe they don't have the
correct technique so yeah you want
stable relatively easy somewhat isolated
but not completely isolated movements
that are good substitutes for those big
lifts again not perfect but then that
also brings me to one other option and
that's overcoming isometrics overcoming
isometrics being pushing or pulling
against the immovable Force something
I've spoken about on this channel before
for I just purchased myself an ISO chain
this is a device where you get a handle
attached to the ground by a chain you
then stand on a platform and attempt to
curl the chain or deadlift the chain or
squat the chain but of course it's not
going anywhere and it's measuring the
amount of force that you're putting in
I'm not going to go into this in a lot
of detail right now because I've talked
about it before but basically it allows
you to exert maximum Force for the total
duration of the rep so that's normally 6
seconds and there's no strength curve
here and there's no momentum here so you
can push or pull for the entire time
recruting as many muscle fibers as
possible building that intramuscular
coordination that's the missing piece of
the puzzle for a lot of these exercises
and that should allow you to exert more
strength because you're building that
neural Drive the ability to recruit
those muscle fibers you want to do it in
a couple of different positions within
the movement and because it's not a
dynamic activity it's not a total
replacement for these actual lifts but
it'll certainly carry over you might
even see some strength gains and of
course you can combine this with a
mechanical drop set so when it comes to
building strength there are two main
things you need to consider the neural
drive that's your ability to recruit as
many of the bigger motor units in your
muscle as possible and the thickness and
the ratio of fast twitch muscle fiber
those being the muscle fibers that are
strongest and most explosive the issue a
lot of people have when training outside
of the gym and not with very heavy
weights is that they don't manage to do
both of these things at once you can
actually engage the fast twitch muscle
fibers pretty easily by going to
exhaustion thanks to something called
Henman size principle your body will
only use the smallest and weakest motor
units necessary to perform a movement so
if you use a lightweight you're not
going to engage as many bigger motor
units as many faster twitched muscle
fibers because you don't need them to
execute that movement you'll recruit
these smallest ones and then add to
these as the demand becomes greater if
however you fatigue the slower twitch
muscle fibers then all that's left are
the faster twitch muscle fibers and the
bigger motor units so now your nervous
system has no option but to recruit
those bigger ones this is why it is
perfectly possible to build some
strength by training to failure and at
the same time to trigger hypertrophy at
the same time training to failure is
fantastic for metabolic stress and
muscle damage so in terms of building
muscle going to failure and using drop
sets is a very effective
method you see that shaking in my arm
that's my body recruiting my fast twitch
muscle fibers because I've exhausted the
slow twitch muscle fibers so when you
push a lighter amount of weight your
body will use the smallest motor unit
it's necessary containing the slower
twitch muscle fibers when they all give
up when they've all become fatigued and
you're still placing that Demand on your
body it has no option but to recruit the
larger motor units and that vibration
comes because those big motor units
aren't designed for fine gradations of
force they exert more Force so rather
than a smooth increase in power you get
a jolt that's how you know you're
actually engaging your fast twitch
fibers
and those bigger stronger motor units
even using body weight or lighter
weights and strength gains will come to
some degree doing this as well the
problem is though that if you only
engage the faster twitch muscle fibers
and bigger motor units at the end of
your workout when you're already
fatigued you're not training that neural
drive that ability to quickly and
powerfully recruit those fast twitch
muscle fibers so there's a couple of
options here one is what we've already
discussed to use harder variations of
movements that do require more max
strength the problem is that many of
these are quite skill-based and utilize
Lots different muscle groups at once so
one other option is to use explosive
movements so things like jump squats or
a kettle bell jump squat these are
fantastic for increasing your rate of
force production your ability to
explosively cool on those massive motor
units this on its own won't cause a lot
of muscle damage there's less of an
eccentric component and therefore you
can combine this as part of a drop set
in order to get those benefits as well
and the other option is overcoming
isometrics so for example you might do
an overcoming isometric squat or you
might do a kettle bell jump Squat and
then you're going to move straight into
air squats or goblet squats and then
what you're going to do from there is go
to failure now what you're doing is
you're training that Nal drive that
maximum recruitment of motor units at
the start of the workout when you're
fresh but at the same time you're also
going to muscular failure so that you're
recruiting those fast twitched muscle
fibers so that you're creating that
muscle damage and really stimulating
growth so this way you're still getting
two of the main benefits of training
with a really really heavy weight you're
just kind of separating those benefits
out what I will say is ease into this go
gentle with it to start with as with any
of these things particularly with they
becoming isometrics these can leave you
kind of dizzy and they're really
fatiguing so going straight into another
exercise can be a bit risky this is why
you want to make sure you're doing a
very simple Clos chain exercise or one
that you can bail out of very quickly
and easily of course you don't
necessarily need an ISO chain to perform
overcoming isometrics you can do this by
trying to deadlift a car if you are at
the gym then of course you can load a
weight up heavier than you can lift you
can push against door frames you can
push against walls all kinds of
different things and a great way to use
this is to Target your sticking points
whichever point in the movement you
finding most difficult and this is a
really great way to smash through some
plateaus even when you can't get to the
gym of course I should also mention at
this point that you don't actually need
to perform this as a drop set if you do
find that a bit too intensive then
there's nothing wrong with performing
your overcoming isometrics or your
explosive movements at the start of a
workout then performing your Dynamic
exercises later on in the workout that
said there are some benefits to doing
one directly after the other if you
perform your overcoming isometrics right
at the start and then immediately follow
that up with the dynamic exercises
you'll benefit from something called
post potentiation activation what this
basically means is because you've just
sent that really strong neural signal
it's now easier for you to recruit those
motor units subsequently just play
around with the variables and that's
really the point here because a lot of
the training we do is kind of arbitrary
because it's been shown to be an
efficient method when you really
understand what's going on inside your
body and you understand your own goals
then you can start manipulating these
different factors in order to achieve
those goals in a myriad of different
ways and sometimes maybe even faster or
more efficiently in other words there's
no such thing as a lack of resources
only a lack of resourcefulness so be
creative and find ways to push yourself
and you can increase your max strength
even from home so hope you found this
video useful interesting guys if you did
then please leave a like and share
around that would help me out immensely
let me know in the comments how you
train for strength even when you don't
have access to the heaviest weights
actually have a training program that
uses some of these principles super
functional training 2.0 the protein
performance system incorporates
overcoming isometrics and a form of drop
set that I call Gauntlet set so if you
want to try it out for yourself then
there's a link in the description down
below it comes with an 85 Plus page
ebook and over 2 hours of instructional
video whatever the case thank you so
much for watching this one guys and I'll
see you next time bye for
now by the way guys this video is
sponsored by Squarespace Squarespace is
a website building platform that makes
it extremely easy for anyone to get a
website up and running with zero coding
knowledge necessary and in a very short
period of time I'm talking minutes s
space does this by letting you start
from a template there's loads and loads
to choose from that you like the looks
of and then customizing it really
intuitively by just dragging and
dropping different elements all around
whilst you can get a website up and
running in minutes it does have all of
the different features you could need in
order to grow your business to whatever
Heights you might need it's got Advanced
formatting features so you can create
beautiful looking blog posts and
schedule them to post whenever you want
it's got analytics a fully featured
commenting system it's got social media
integration it has gated members only
content if you want to create a revenue
stream from your website and it has
e-commerce of course for selling a range
of products not only does it have all
these great features out of the gate you
can actually add even more by using
plugins provided by the community so the
sky really is the limit in terms of your
e-commerce you can add things like
global Shipping Inventory management tax
reconciliation all that good stuff the
great thing about Squarespace is that it
evens the playing field it means that
anyone can get a website up and running
whether it's to promote business or just
as a form of self-expression I think
this is a great great tool and if you
want to learn more then go to
squarespace.com and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com by near in
order to get 10% off your first domain
or website thanks again to Squarespace
for sponsoring this video and thanks to
you guys for sticking around until the
end bye for now